imágenes de dron muestran la magnitud de
la destrucción al menos
264.000 apartamentos quedaron destruidos
luego de los devastadores terremotos del
6 de febrero en Turquía y Siria
sin embargo entre las montañas de
escombros todavía se encuentra vida los
casos son extraordinarios
[Música]
esta familia permaneció 296 horas bajo
los escombros los padres sobrevivieron
pero el niño murió después de su rescate
por deshidratación
taja erdem de 17 años fue rescatado en
la ciudad de adillamán en el sur de
Turquía grabó su experiencia bajo los
escombros cuando pensaba que iba a morir
al otro lado de la frontera en Siria las
operaciones de rescate finalizaron Hace
unos días la fase actual consiste en
asistencia humanitaria los
sobrevivientes y damnificados
[Música]
hoy llegó un cargamento italiano que
consta de 50 toneladas de equipos para
satisfacer las necesidades del pueblo
sirio en cualquier parte del país
Italia y la comunidad europea
respondieron al llamado de auxilio de
bachara la Sad quien solicitó a la Unión
Europea la activación del mecanismo de
Protección Civil esto ha permitido la
actuación conjunta del bloque en la
entrega de ayuda humanitaria a pesar de
las sanciones internacionales que pesan
sobre el régimen sirio
no es momento de hablar de política
debemos unirnos
Estados Unidos país que no reconoce al
régimen de vallar al asad prometió 85
millones de dólares en ayuda tanto a
Turquía como a Siria a través del
programa said por su parte el secretario
general de la ONU Antonio Gutiérrez
solicitó a la comunidad internacional
recaudar 1400 millones de dólares para
atender a más de 5 millones de
damnificados en ambos países